look I live in a socialist country no
one dislike socialism as much as I do
it's totally intolerable I don't want
anybody to live like that I don't want
Americans to live like that I'm not on
that side but if they're going to tell
me that economics which is the science
of the choosing free consenting
individual can answer the basic problems
America has today that's false
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sundays special I'm excited
to welcome this week Yoram hezonia he's
president of the Herzl Institute in
Jerusalem he currently serves as the
chairman of the Edmund Burke foundation
in Washington and he's the author of the
brand-new and fantastic book the virtue
of nationalism your own thanks so much
for stopping by thanks for having me so
first of all we violated the taboo on
only one yarmulke per show so we can
start off with the fact that I believe
you're the first Orthodox Jew who is not
me who's been on this show so I think
there's more of us coming well why don't
we start with the the kind of basic
premise of the book so the nationalism
obviously has come under significant
assault from some on the right mostly on
the left the the idea of nationalism
being seen as something inherently bad
particularly since President Trump has
picked up the mast the mantle of
nationalism and used that sort of
language so how do you define
nationalism well I don't actually think
this is because of Trump I mean the the
assault by by communists by liberals on
nationalism is already in full swing
after World War two so we've already
seen a few generations of people just
trying to hang you know every political
evil in the world on nationalism of the
nationalism I grew up with is is a
principled stance that says that the
world is governed best when many
different nations are able to chart
their own course independently without
interference meaning cultivating their
own traditions their own laws their
their pursuing their own interests and
for three four hundred years that was a
mainstay of certainly of the
anglo-american tradition but more
generally of the the way that Europe
under understood the political order was
that nation should be independent one
from one another and it's really after
World War two that that you start to see
a vicious attack on nationalism first in
Europe where the argument is World War
one in World War two you know those were
caused by nationalism by having
independent nations what's the answer
well European Union let's eliminate
independent nations that's eliminate
borders and that's supposed to be the
answer more surprising is that Americans
have picked it
and I I would say Reagan was still a
nationalist Thatcher was still a
nationalist in the way that I'm defining
it but by the time you get to the fall
of the Berlin Wall George HW Bush
talking about the New World Order where
the New World Order means a single rule
of a single law that's going to be
imposed if force by force if necessary
on the whole world that's already a post
national situation between Reagan and
Trump all the American presidents and
almost every political leader
significant political leader in Europe
or post nationalist
so in a second I'm going to ask you
about how we define a nation in order to
find the basis for nationalism but first
let's talk about your life insurance so
it's that's how many year it's open
enrollment season and that means you're
probably looking at life insurance
through your employer well to properly
provide for your family most people will
need ten times life insurance coverage
you get through your job which means
your employer life insurance is probably
leaving you underinsured and that's why
you need policy genius policy genius is
the easy way to shop for a life
insurance plan that isn't tied to your
job in minutes you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find your best
price once you apply the policy genius
team handles all the paperwork all the
red tape for life insurance you buy
through policy genius stays with you
even if you leave your job and policy
genius doesn't just make it easy to get
life insurance they can also help you
find the right home and auto insurance
disability insurance too so when you are
looking at your workplace benefits this
month make sure to double check your
life insurance options then head on over
to policy genius com get quotes apply in
minutes it is your one-stop shop for
insurance again is the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance and auto
insurance and disability insurance and
home insurance and all the rest go be an
adult go to policy genius.com
and ensure that your family is covered
all right so let's talk about what it
means to be a nation so obviously
there's been a lot of controversy in the
recent past about what constitutes a
nation what doesn't constitute a nation
conflicts over the territorial
boundaries of nations have obviously
sparked Wars in the past with for
example during World War two Germany
claiming that German ethnics were living
in areas that were not specifically
German actually were part of the
termination and therefore justifying
territorial broadening in order do that
you seen the Russians do this in Crimea
most recently so how do you define a
nation well
a nation is a group of tribes that share
some kind of a heritage
all right that's usually usually
includes a religion often includes a
language and and a history of joining
together in common cause against against
mutual enemies so the word in a nation
that that's where we get the Greek word
ethnos ethnic so the Greeks even though
they they live two city-states they
never had a nation-state they never
United as an as a nation in antiquity
but the Greeks knew that there was such
a thing as a Greek ethnos they spoke the
same same language they had the same
culture even though they were war with
one another so that that's kind of a
natural thing that you find throughout
human history the question of whether it
the world should consist of of national
states of unifying the nations under a
single heading it really becomes a an
important question and political thought
with the Hebrew Bible because the Hebrew
Bible knows a world in which there's all
these empires that try to conquer the
whole world that the Babylonians the
Assyrians they have their gods tell them
let's bring peace and prosperity to the
world by going out and conquering all
the nations the earth and suppressing
needless conflict right that's actually
you know not an unreasonable argument
but the the prophets know about these
conflicting imperial aspirations to
conquer the world they know about
tribesmen you know Abraham goes to live
as a tribesman they know about tribes
and clans and they put this new idea on
the table God says to Abraham I'll make
of you a great nation he gives Moses
borders and forbids Israel from going
out and conquering the neighbors as far
as we know that's the first time that
any God in human history has given
borders to his own nation and says no I
gave the lands to the other peoples too
so you don't cross your borders that
that's where the original vision of a
world of independent nations starts and
the the modern sensibility that of
self-determination
that there's there's a kind of justice
and a kind of freedom that attaches to
this kind of world that actually enters
the modern age with the return to the
old testament by people's like the
English the Scots the Dutch the the
French to an extent so this is an
example of where we actually have Hebrew
Bible Old Testament shaping the modern
world in in a decisive and crucial way
so how do we define nation to avoid some
of the pitfalls of for example the the
ethno nationalists right the all right
as they they call themselves the the
idea that there should be a white
america or people who claim that that
what nation really is is pure ethnicity
or pure race how do we organize people
so that in our own minds and in terms of
defining a nation it allows for
multi-ethnic members the traditional
idea of a nation going back all the way
to the Bible he's not constructed on
race right the this is this is a crucial
difference I mean you know that that
throughout the Bible we see people
joining the Jewish joining the Jewish
people most famously Ruth the Moabitess
was a Moabite and she comes over and she
says your people will be my people and
your God will be my god no she's able to
convert not simply because she adopts
the Israelite God but also because she
says there's an existing people with an
existing heritage and I'm going to join
that I'm going to take up the
characteristics of that heritage there's
lots of other examples the the
Israelites leave Egypt and Egyptians
come with them and they get absorbed
into into the Jewish people or or Moses
inviting is his father-in-law Jethro to
join the Jewish people there's all sorts
of examples this is a a view of what a
nation is which is based on inheritance
right so so partly it has to do with
with birth you know with who who your
mother is and who your father is
but adoption is always possible on this
view that a family can adopt and a tribe
can adopt in nations can adopt so it's
much much more flexible
then this caricature that you get both
from the left and the right which claims
the nationalism is about some kind of
racial homogeneity and there there is no
homogeneity I mean if every nation is
internally diverse the question if
you're nationalists is how can I
strengthen the commonality so that the
the bonds of mutual loyalty will be
firmer so that the nation doesn't
doesn't disintegrate into into civil war
now these guys on on the alt-right that
you're talking about they don't have the
slightest interest either in you know
what the biblical idea of a nation is or
even what the traditional anglo-american
idea of a nation is they think that you
can get you can determine you know what
kind of what they call nationality it's
they think you can get it out of a
test-tube you know like you you go take
a blood test and and that determines
what nation you're from there's never
been anything like that in in you know
in in the history of Judaism and
Christianity and and and it's crucial I
think for us to fight this idea which is
gaining strength and it's kind of
horrifying to see it gained strength
because you'll you'll notice that as
soon as you judge people on the basis of
well they they say it's not skin color
it's you know it's DNA but doesn't make
any difference that as soon as you judge
people like that then ideas are out the
window then the heritage is out the
window it doesn't does it doesn't matter
if you're if you're Hebrew speaker if
you if you know the Bible if you respect
the rabbinic tradition all that goes
stuff goes out the window and it all
comes down to this ghastly simplistic
argument over you know they think they
think the Jews are a race when I get too
into arguments with these people they I
try to explain to them that way you know
we have Jews of every possible racial
background in in in in my Orthodox
community in Jerusalem and they say no
that they can't possibly be true you're
lying it's not true this is a terrible
terrible direction for for American for
the West to be going by the way the
whole idea of a white nation is itself
kind of wacko when was there ever a
white nation I mean there were there was
a French nation there was an English
nation there's German nation
American nation there's never any white
nation I mean this is this is like a a
an artificial construct that they've
they've come up with
imitating obviously racialist politics
from from Europe before World War two
and we know how that ends and if we
don't want to see that then we're gonna
have to take this head-on and the way to
take it head-on is to say you don't know
what a nation is you don't understand
what a nation is let's talk about
historically what a nation has been in
Western civilization and then maybe you
know maybe you'll know something about
it
from from a different angle one of these
hacks on nationalism has been that that
basically nation should be defined
purely by creed it's purely a credo
phenomenon particularly in the United
States that the United States was
founded under the under the philosophy
of the Declaration of Independence and
carried forward through the institutions
of the Constitution of the United States
so what is wrong with the idea of a of a
purely cradle nation as opposed to a a
more holistic view of what nation it
constitutes what's like going to the
opposite extreme I mean what are you
gonna do if someone doesn't accept
unless somebody's like a like a Burkean
and doesn't doesn't accept the
Declaration of Independence as as
capturing the the the essence of America
so they're a burcham so what they're not
good America and I think you can be a
good American can love the Constitution
you can love the people you can love the
heritage you can want to fight for it
and and not be a lock in I mean look
America is just not a religion right
it's not it's not a replacement for
Christianity so I sometimes I get the
feeling with some of my you know some of
some of my colleagues who want to say
that America is a creed that really what
they're doing is they're saying that
they're saying I want to replace
Christianity with something like
Christianity but let's say without Jesus
so to say America is liberalism and I I
think this is it's it's historically
incorrect but it's also are you sure
that that's something that you would
want I mean the beauty of a nation is
that it allows an internal pluralism I
said before that that all nations are
internally diverse and the moment that
you start you know trying to figure out
what the Creed is that everybody has to
sign
- well then you're in church territory a
nation has to be able to have a much
greater flexibility for different kinds
of people all nations do and and certain
and and certainly America does so I just
think that's a mistake I mean I
understand why they're trying to do it
but I think they're also denying an
important part of America's history
which is that that the American people
the American nation actually for most of
its history had a content now when I say
content I don't mean every single person
was signed up for it but I mean a
dominant culture that culture was an Old
Testament culture it was a Protestant
culture it was it was a common-law
culture and and of course spoke the
English language and only if you
understand that up until World War two
for most of America's history that that
was America's common heritage that held
held the nation together only if you
understand that can you explain
historical phenomena like why is it the
United States never allowed a state into
the Union until there was a majority a
Christian english-speaking population
that would you know that that would
follow the common law what why didn't
they they could have there were many
opportunities to to to have states that
were Spanish speaking or Polynesian
speaking in Hawaii but they didn't do it
and so so the far right the the
alt-right they want to tell us oh it's
because they're because they're their
race conscious I think that's a bunch of
baloney it had nothing to do with race
it had to do with the fact that there
was such a thing as an American heritage
that held held the country together the
people could assimilate into if they
were from some other kind of background
and that's something that America really
has lost since World War two it it's
becoming radically more diverse not just
but because of immigration but also
because of multiculturalism also because
of this ideology that that America is
different from every other nation in the
world and doesn't have a cultural
heritage that people can be assimilated
into now America has such a cultural
heritage the question is America's
fraying right now
I mean it's actually flying apart
and and our Americans going to be
willing to turn back to their own
heritage and to reconnect to it I think
that's the question of this generation
so in just a second only ask you about
self-determination and whether every
nation deserves to have its own space or
whether there is in fact a moral minimum
to which nations have to aspire in order
to achieve sort of a moral worth of
having self-determination but first
let's talk about your internet security
have you ever wondered why internet
access is so much cheaper these days
like 30 or 40 bucks a month that's
because the Internet service providers
like Comcast and AT&T they're not just
making money off your subscription fees
anymore they are also making money from
spying on your internet activity and
then selling your history and data it's
a big tech companies which is why I use
Express VPN to make sure they never get
hold of my data as we speak right now
there's actually a huge fight going on
in Congress where ISPs are lobbying
against encrypted DNS in browsers why
well because encryption makes it much
harder to spy on you and a lot of big
companies Time Warner or Verizon they're
not gonna like that the best way to make
sure that 100% of your data is encrypted
from your ISP is with expressvpn
expressvpn creates a secure tunnel
between all your devices in the internet
so everything you do online is encrypted
not even your isp can track and collect
data on you expressvpn works on all your
devices not just your phone and a
computer works on tablets and smart TVs
even your router so you and your whole
family can always be protected can't
stress this enough expressvpn is really
easy it's really simple you just open up
the app you tap one button to connect
you're done your data is your business
protected and expressvpn calm slash been
again that's expressive VPN calm slash
many get a special deal three extra
months of expressvpn protection for free
that's expressed VPN calm slash Bend
learn more once more expressvpn calm
slash been alright so let's talk about a
moral minimum with regard to nations so
obviously there are plenty of different
peoples all around the world who
identify as nations and many of them
have used the sort of Woodrow Wilson's a
justification of self-determination in
order to claim that they ought to be
given territory and we've seen that many
of these things have ended in tears for
even the people who want
self-determination is there sort of a
baseline of human rights or philosophy
that has to be attained by a nation in
order for them in your view to attain a
claim for for self-determination
try real hard
in the book to emphasize that I'm not a
you I'm not a utopian and and you can
create a utopian you know utopian
nationalist theory that's going to try
to answer these kinds of questions
mathematically I think it's it's it's
actually impossible to do and the
baseline is what John Stuart Mill called
national cohesion or fellow-feeling the
baseline is in order for a nation to be
independent let's say that you know we
accept this principle that it's the
world is governed best when there are
many independent nations now in order to
get into the club you're going to have
to you're gonna have to be able to do
things that are that are very practical
alright let's take the Kurds as an
example I I've said many times that I
think the Kurds deserve an independent
an independent national state this is 30
million people suffered endless
persecution they history going back to
the Medes their own language Meserve a
state in some kind of an abstract sense
and and and I support that but in in
practice if a nation is not capable of
mustering the military and economic
strength to be able to hold together and
to fight off the neighbors are going to
try to prevent them then there's not
going to be a nation you can say they
have a right to a nation if you want it
you know if you think expressing it that
way would be helpful but in practice you
can't have a right to to national
independence if if you can't actually
secure it and so so everywhere you look
you have to make these kinds of these
kinds of decisions and considerations
all right the Navajo are you know we
certainly the Navajo Nation have all the
characteristics of of a nation but
they're not strong enough to be able to
stand in in independently under under
current circumstances so at this time in
history so that they're not going to be
an independent nation I remember
visiting Scotland a few years ago you
know I saw a Braveheart and I was like
yes gah - independence that's you know I
actually think a lot of people in Scott
also saw Braveheart and their you know
so it it's really stirring and
everything but I spent a few weeks you
know just talking to everybody I could
you know the front from from professors
to restaurant owners asking them about
this and and is it is it really worth
taking apart the United Kingdom after a
few hundred years of brilliant
collaboration between English and Scots
under a under single state and I was not
convinced I mean lots of people said
they wanted independence and then they
said we want independence but we want to
be part of the European Union so that
that sounds to me like like like an
argument that just doesn't make any much
sense you have to have a real good
reason to take apart your country I mean
I'm I'm understating it a really really
good reason and it doesn't seem to me
that they do right I'm opening hearing
other arguments but basically the the
view of a world of national states is
not a view in which every group of
people that says oh you know we've we
have a different culture I mean they
think of India India has you know
fifteen hundred peoples in in India with
with with with their own languages and
many of these are millions and millions
of people but the question will always
come down to are you strong enough
are you cohesive enough to actually be
able to take independence and is it
worth the bloodshed is it worth the the
incredible suffering that that that a
war of independence is going to to bring
on those are those are Prudential
practical considerations which you know
reasonable people can argue about them
in different cases so how do national
interest balance out on the world stage
so what folks who are anti nationalism
would say is that you'll have brief
periods of balance of power where
people's tend to to deter each other to
a certain extent and then you get the
chaos of World War one for example or
you get the chaos of World War two and
why is the EU not a solution to that for
example we haven't had enter any
internet except for Yugoslavia we
haven't had any internecine European
warfare since World War two so why
exactly is internationalism or or the
sub summation of nation-states under a
broader rubric of an
intl of an international institution why
isn't that a better solution than
nationalism itself well this this is a
great question but notice that it is the
imperialist question imperialists for
for 4,000 years imperialists have been
saying if you allow tribes to have their
independence or nations to have their
independence they'll kill one another
and they'll create Wars and and and
that's what we want what we want is to
impose peace on the whole world
and that's not an unreasonable argument
it's just that they that they never
willing to be honest about the cost the
cost is if you're if you're the Roman
Empire or the Assyrian Empire or or the
European Union for that matter if you're
going to you're going to suppress war
across a continent but the cost is going
to be that that there's going to be a
central cent a central power almost
always dominated by a specific nation in
this this particular case in Germany and
it's their culture that's going to make
the decisions they're gonna draw the
boundaries they're gonna make the
decisions about what what's allowed and
what's not allowed so let's say you're
an Italian so today to be an Italian
under what's effectively a German
imperial rule it's not exactly Imperial
rule because because it's actually
American force that's holding the thing
in place not not German armed forces but
in terms of of who's making the
decisions well look if the Italians that
they had a recent election which the
Germans don't like the the Finance
Ministry that the Italian people want to
a point and so the Germans say they
leave veto it and they impose a Finance
Minister the Germans don't like the
Italians budget the the national budget
so so the Germans will make a decision
about what the limits of the Italian
budget are and of course it always turns
out that this is somehow for the best
for Germany now if you are and an
Italian and this doesn't upset you like
you you don't feel that your own
personal freedom and self your personal
freedom is being impinged upon by having
the Germans making decisions about who
your government is so realistically
you're not going to have an independent
country you're going to be part of some
kind of German Empire I'm not going to
tell you you know that's that's the end
of the world but I think when we when
we're talking about the level of
principle ever
principal I think that the prophets had
it right that that having diverse
nations with different kinds of laws
each one taking responsibility for their
own fate that means they'll decide how
to appoint their own officials they'll
decide how to set their own budget and
of course they're gonna screw it up
right I mean who we're human right we of
course sometimes you screw things up but
the Italian people are the Polish people
or the English people the or the British
are better off being self-reliant
developing the ability to make decisions
for themselves taking the lumps when
they get it wrong and and and finding a
way to come back
it's that competition among independent
nations with different traditions by
trial and error trying to figure out
what the best way to live that is what
gave us almost everything in the modern
world that that we love modern science
people forget this was the was the
result of this kind of competition
between between Newton hated French
science he hated Cartesian science it
was a nationalist motivation bye-bye
English scientists that that gave us a
lot of the the physics and the worldview
that we know and you can say the same
thing about about the development of
democracy the development of the stock
exchange in in the Netherlands was the
result of competition among nations and
you can just keep going competition
among nations gives you laboratories in
which you can experiment and try
different things out and Empire means
that all that competition is going to be
suppressed it's going to be suppressed
and homogenized and the bigger it is the
more oppressive it is this is this is
also a John Stuart Mill argument but you
can't there there is no way that you can
have one government that is over dozens
and dozens of nations without many many
of them and ending up being oppressed
and suppressed will jump back in with
the next question in just a moment but
before we do I wanted to let our
listeners know we have a special offer
for you this weekend and this weekend
only recently you might have heard me
talk about our all-new all-access tear
at Daily wire where you get to have live
conversations with the daily wear crew
in addition
all the great things that come with our
insider plan this weekend when you
subscribe to all access over at daily
wire comm we are throwing in two signed
best-selling books along with the
tumbler and our entire catalogue of
fantastic content and discussion
features we're giving you a copy of my
number one New York Times best seller
the right side of history and Michael
Mills awful bestseller reasons to vote
for Democrats clearly one of these is
worthy reading material on the other is
a drink coaster but either way all you
have to do is use the promo code DW
books when you subscribe to all access
over at daily wire.com again that's code
DW books to get your signed copies over
at daily wire.com so is there any cause
for nations intervening in the internal
affairs of other nations so for example
you know if the idea is that nations are
best when the world's best one nations
are self-governing what would be the
cause for for example intervening in
Rwandan genocide or intervening in the
midst of a holocaust by Germany even if
let's say that they had stayed in their
borders and they had just decided to
murder all the Jews in their borders or
let's say in the United States where
black slaves were being held in the
southern half of the United States and
the Union declared basically that this
was going to stop what it was eventually
going to stop and the South seceded why
was the South wrong in that particular
case they say we have our own culture we
have our own sort of philosophy that we
have and it's none of your business
whether we decide to enslave Africans
who we have imported here well let's
look let's distinguish two things I mean
this is this is obviously an absolutely
crucial question first of all
realistically nations do interfere in
one another's business and when when
when I say I'm a nationalist and I argue
that you know that you should be a
nationalist what I'm saying is actually
that the that the constant interference
in one another's business that there
should be some kind of principle that
actually puts a stop to that because if
you don't then then everybody is you you
know the the the English spent a hundred
years trying to conquer France injured
did during the Middle Ages if five
generations of Englishmen like dying
trying to conquer France the idea is
that the most natural thing is everybody
interferes in everybody else's business
and we're looking for a principle that
people could agree on that would allow
some of this
to stop alright so in other words we're
trying to set up a situation where we
minimize the natural tendency to just
bully everybody and to try to take over
everything and interfere in one
another's business all the time so
that's only going to that this can be
successful to a certain degree and and
hopefully enough of a degree so that we
can create this you know the this world
of free nations that I'm talking about
but I I don't in the book or anywhere
else think that that means that you know
that we stop being human beings we stop
having moral obligations I mean if if
you have the power to get into Rwanda or
Cambodia
you know when millions are people
hundreds of thousand millions of people
are being killed you have the power to
get in there put a stop to it and pull
out without ending up you know governing
the place for the next hundred years
then I'd say you I I'd say you do have a
moral obligation to do it I don't I
don't think there's any question that
that that is an obligation if you have
that kind of ability here's what the
issue is I think the actual issue is is
Americans for example who say we're the
world's policemen we have a moral
obligation to impose a law on the entire
planet we have a moral obligation to to
to ramp up service in the American
military to the degree that that
basically Americans are just like beat
cops on every corner everywhere in the
world and so when people start doing
something wrong all right we start
bombing because we're the policemen
we're in charge we we use force and then
then you get Bosnia Kosovo Afghanistan
Iraq Somalia and Libya you I mean
there's no end to it Panama like why not
just invade everything because the the
imperial principle is we Americans know
the answer we have we have the truth we
know the answer we know how to run the
world and and so we should we have a
moral obligation to just run it to
impose our will on everyone and I'm
saying no first of all you know much as
I love American Americans they're not
they're not as smart as they sometimes
think they are and they don't actually
know how to run Iraq they don't actually
know how to run Libya the the
they don't actually know if the answer
to that question and this is also this
is a I think a crucial thing that
Americans actually need to get out of
the the story of their history and the
last generation or two is is the
humility to understand no not everybody
in the world wants America running their
country and if America tries to do it
America doesn't necessarily know how to
do it right so I I want to make a a big
draw a big distinction between the the
most extreme cases where you have the
power to intervene to stop what what
what really is a genocide you could get
in get out and stop it and most
political cases where okay so so you
know the Iraq is a brutal regime and
they do terrible things and they violate
you know human rights in the worst ways
I that that's for sure
but the question is so America
intervenes did fewer people die because
America intervened I'd I don't think so
I mean I actually I don't know the
actual numbers because they're not
publicized but I would say that in the
Middle East in the last generation maybe
a million people have died in it as a
consequence of American intervention and
the domino effect that came from it you
know that that's not easy to justify
tearing apart foreign societies because
you have an idea of how you think that
they should be run so in a second I want
to ask you about when US intervention is
necessary in order to check ambitions of
other nations because we've talked about
when it would be necessary in terms of
sort of humane interventions and when it
would not be necessary when the United
States is going in on on bad pretexts
for example but I want to ask about you
know countering the the other potential
hegemon who want to get involved in
world affairs but first I love my helix
sleep mattress let me say I don't get
enough sleep when I'm on a mattress it
better be a good mattress good news
helix sleep is my mattress helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete and matches your body type
and sleep references to the perfect
mattress for you whether you're a side
sleeper or a hot sleeper whether you
like a plush or firm bed with helix
there's no more confusion no more
compromising Hewett sleep is rated the
number one mattress by GQ and Wired
magazine CNN calls it the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on just go to helix sleep calm
/ been take their two-minute sleep quiz
they will match you to a customized
mattress that gives you the best sleep
of your life I know I sleep on one every
night for couples Helix can even split
the mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they've got a
10 year warranty you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but that's not gonna happen
you're gonna love it
helix is offering up to a hundred and
twenty-five bucks off all mattress
orders for our listeners get up to a
hundred and twenty five bucks off at
helix sleep calm / Ben that's helix
sleep calm / Benton from two one hundred
and twenty five dollars off your
mattress order once more helix sleep
calm / Ben ok so let's talk for a second
about what the US has role in terms of
foreign policy is encountering the
ambitions of other nations so to take a
couple of obvious examples Russia
invades Crimea and the United States
says you ought not do that or Russia
invades Georgia and the United States
says you ought not do that but Russia
sort of stays there which is what
they've done in in both places
effectively sort of half in Georgia and
half not but Crimea they've fully
internalized into into Russia it seems
what is the United States justified in
getting involved in something like that
and that has some historic ramifications
too because obviously World War two
begins on under these pretenses I mean
it precedes on the pretext of the west
meaning Great Britain effectively
guaranteeing the sovereignty of Poland
and the Germans and we just want to take
this little slice right here and Britain
saying well you've taken enough slices
the answer is no couldn't the same
argument be made with regard to you know
what more people have died if they just
allowed the the Germans to take Danzig
for example I I think the German example
is I mean you you know it's it's
overused right and I I want to try to
refine it just a little bit if you read
mine Kampf and it's not like something
like I'm recommending to your audience
go read mine I think we all get that
right but if you do read it it's really
hard to miss the fact that that Hitler
sees the faith of Germany of the German
nation as being Lord of the earth and
mistress of the globe alright this is
this is a book about about world's
domination and the there is a difference
and I admit that this is look
politics is hard you can't always figure
it out exactly but there there is a
difference between between a nation
which is trying to unify the ethnic
group let's call it a border dispute
okay they're one of the real problems
and this is a genuine genuine problem
with nationalism as a as a form of
political order is that they're always
border disputes there always are you can
never you you can never never get
everybody who's supposed to be
theoretically on one side of the border
on to you you can never perfect it and
what that means is that that as opposed
to imperialism where you just conquer
everything in a nationalist World Order
there's always going to be points of
friction so India and Pakistan have you
know long-standing border disputes in
Kashmir Israel and the Arabs right the
Jews and the Arabs have a border dispute
in injured and Samaria the English and
the Irish have a border dispute which is
is back it's back again in business over
North Ireland and those things are
natural and they sometimes they do cause
Wars what a what I think what I want to
do is I want to try to distinguish and
in the book I make this argument greater
length between the basically inevitable
tensions and frictions which sometimes
erupt into into these these local Wars
and obviously they can do lots of damage
but they don't create world wars and
they're all these world they're these
sort of stock world wars that haunt the
imagination of Western people the 30
Years War the Napoleonic Wars the First
World War the Second World War the Cold
War that's kind of like that those are
the stock Wars that everybody's always
saying well if you have serb nationalism
then boom World War 1 I think this is a
bunch of baloney I don't buy The
sleepwalkers thesis I think that when
you when you go into any of these cases
what you will find is there has to be in
order to in order to start to bring
about these the deaths of tens of
millions of people like these horrific
wars there has to be some imperial power
which is has some ideology which says
we rule by right right it can be
Catholicism which is the thirty years
war we're gonna we're gonna rule all of
all of Europe and from from there the
world or it can be the Napoleonic Wars
where it's some kind of revolutionary
liberalism that Napoleon is trying to
force down on the throats of everybody
in Europe and as a consequence five
million people died these are not border
disputes take a biography of Napoleon
and just see what he does he conquers
one country and then another and then
another and then another that that's an
imperialist mindset and my argument is
that what we if we want a decent world
that's it's never gonna it's not a
utopian world but it's one that's not
gonna have these kind these kinds of
demolition-derby wars that that set out
to simply reconstruct all of
civilization well look for the
imperialism look for the ideology that's
driving one nation to say we're gonna be
mistress of mistress of the globe we're
gonna conquer the entire world that
that's the decisive question so in that
context how would you rate the threats
of for example Russia and China
respectively well I think I think both
of them are hard cases both both Russia
and China have long Imperial traditions
all right it's not we're not talking
about you know a Poland er in Ireland
where we'd be kind of surprised if they
you know if they set out to try to take
over the whole world
Russia has many centuries and China
millennia of Imperial traditions and
we're not going to change that I don't I
don't have any reason to think that
that's going to change in you know in
our lifetimes so the question for
Americans then is that's a real
challenge and it's a real threat there's
it's not it's not a pretend threat and
how what's the best way of going about
stopping it now I sort of came came into
my awareness of politics during the
Reagan Thatcher years when I was in
college I was a Reagan Revolution er and
I founded the Princeton Tory and which
is still there 35 years later in crowd
and and I I remember those days I think
really quite quite clearly Reagan was
was not about invading other countries
so that we could you know govern them I
mean the only thing the Reagan Reagan
ever invaded was Grenada and we're
talking we're talking about you know a
week-long intervention twenty five
servicemen lost their lives I mean that
was it that was you know Reagan fought
the entire end of the Cold War opposing
a real empire that was a real threat to
the world opposing them without America
invading other countries now the way I
see it this is a continuation of
American policy during during world war
ii where america's view right the
Roosevelts view was we we the
god-fearing democracies we have we've an
alliance of independent countries we're
coming to liberate conquered countries
in Europe that's our goal is to free and
to give back their self-determination
and their independence the countries
that have been occupied by one of these
two empires I said that that's Reagan
nationalism that's Thatcher's
nationalism is is is it's not our
business to be policing everything in
the world we we have to find a way to to
create an alliance of nations and
political movements that have a mutual
interest in trying to fight the Soviet
Union that that's not the same as Pax
Americana America is in charge here for
all eternity it's something completely
different and that's what I think we
should be trying to recapture so to
change the topic I'm gonna talk a little
bit about American domestic politics and
philosophy so you've talked in the past
about your objections to classical
liberalism now no I have a friend Dave
Rubin who constantly cites himself as
sort of a classical liberal which seems
to sort of cross over in broad strokes
with libertarianism just the basic
non-aggression principle and that the
government has no job regulating
anything that is consensual activity
you've been even critical to a certain
extent of classical liberalism how do
you distinguish between conservatism and
classical liberalism conservatives first
of all these these terms nationalism
liberalism conservatism it's important
to be aware all these terms are
18th century terms so when we trace
their histories I mean these ideas
really are much older than 19th century
but we traced their histories it's
always a little bit anachronistic so but
let's take someone who's sort of
everybody kind of agrees is the you know
the conservative his Edmund Burke Burke
is not the first conservative because he
himself stands for an Anglo tradition
that goes goes back many centuries and
that's the way he saw it but but since
everybody agrees that he's a
conservative so so let's take him Edmund
Burke spent his career arguing a version
he didn't he didn't explicitly oppose
the British Empire he wasn't trying to
overthrow it but all of his major fights
were to help in the self-determination
of the American people the Irish people
India which was controlled by the
British at the time is a very very
strong sense that the British cannot sit
in London and make decisions for all
these other countries in the world
that's simply not possible you it can't
be just and it can't lead to freedom
that that's is that's kind of
fundamental now Burke is sees the world
in terms of nations just like the bible
does inherits a common law tradition you
know of thinkers like Selden and 4sq and
coke hale these thinkers all see the
world in terms of nations the way that
the bible does and what holds these
nations together is a love of an
inheritance a tradition i already
already said it's not homogenous every
every nation is internally diverse but
there is some kind of a tradition but
Burke thinks the English tradition is
simply the the the the best tradition of
government that there has ever been the
the freest and he's talking about
English Christianity and the common law
and and obviously the the the English
language now putting the nation and its
traditions in the center is extremely
different from what later comes to be
called liberalism liberalism grows out
of that tradition but what what troubles
me when I
you know when I when I talk to my
classical liberal friends is that they
think that enlightenment rationalism but
at some point in the 1700s some really
really smart people figured out a bunch
of Rights which simply are the answer to
you know the way everybody in the world
should live and I I think this is
historically you know utterly false at
what would actually happened is that
over a thousand years of commenting on
the Bible and developing their common
law the English developed almost all of
the rights that are in the American Bill
of Rights and the Americans sort of
copied and pasted it along with most of
the structure of of the American
Constitution and understanding that
that's what happened first of all it
makes you a little bit more humble
because because it means that you don't
sit around thinking oh my brain is so
smart I you know universal truth I know
the answers for all countries for all
time because you know because because
because because I have universal reason
I think that universal reason is
unbelievably dangerous I think it leads
to imperialism I think at least all
sorts of terrible wars and internally it
can also lead to oppression Burks
conservatism is much more moderate
because it's it's realistic
he knows that nations are internally
diverse that they consider consist of
different tribes and he's looking to try
to figure out how can we hold our nation
together where can we draw the borders
so that they are safest how can we
deploy a resources so that our country
goes on for many many more centuries and
I feel that you know Americans actually
had a lot of that Berkey and
common-sense conservatism back a
generation ago before the New World
Order and and I miss it I mean when I
when I was sort of inducted into the
conservative movement in the 1980s you
know we were always talking about how do
you know how do you synthesize Edmund
Burke and Adam Smith and I thought that
was a pretty reasonable place to be
that's a that's a pro religion Pro
nationalists view of
of freedom and and and FreeMarkets is
leading to economic growth I thought
that was a great place to be and
somewhere along the line in the last 30
years the American and English the
British conservatives dropped religion
and dropped nationalism and and and
they're just on free markets and okay I
I also believe in free markets but
they're so far gone they can't tell what
a border is for right and this is really
important to understand classical
liberalism does not in and of itself
have the resources to tell you about
borders for example right if all you do
is study liberal thinkers who when I say
liberal thinker I mean anything core who
thinks that politics can basically be
reduced to free and equal individuals
coming together on the basis of consent
if you think politics can be reduced to
that and you don't understand that that
there's mutual loyalty is to pull tribes
together and the planation x' together
and that any statesman worth anything
has to care about those things well so
you're not going to understand so what's
the problem of open and immigration
let's just flood the country with people
of a different national tradition than
we do what's wrong with it
if you're classical liberal you can't
answer that question and that that's
disturbing to me that Americans can't
answer that question anymore so in a
second I'm gonna provide a basic defense
to that question I also want to ask you
about whether the the kickback to
classical liberalism is coming on the
form of conservatism but in the form of
government intervention ISM and ask
about that in just one second but first
let's talk for a second about how
difficult it is to protect your car from
the water and dirt and salt and some
stuff that really destroys the look and
feel of your car this is why I want to
talk to you about the last code it's a
proprietary versatile durable all-in-one
easy to use all surface do-it-yourself
coating that gives the cars a slick
mirror-like finish in minutes it's also
great for glass vinyl leather stainless
steel counter tops electronic screens
most fabrics and a lot more there's
pretty great gift idea because if you
have a car lover in your family and
their cars constantly getting scuffed up
scratched up looks weather-beaten this
would be the solution the last coat
creates a protective shell on your car
that protects it from UV rays road salt
abrasive soaps Xtreme ten
and more its protection encoding last
for up to six months they've got
thousands of five-star reviews online
and it's a hundred percent made in the
USA plus will give you a 365 day
money-back guarantee and for a limited
time my listeners can get a twenty five
percent discount on a 16 ounce bottle of
last coat it's the most durable all
surface DIY coating technology on the
market for reference and average highs
car takes like 1 or 2 ounces for the
entire coverage to take advantage of
this 25% discount head on over to the
last koat.com slash sunday special type
in sunday 25 at checkout again that's
the last coat calm slash Sunday special
and you type in Sunday 25 at the
checkout to get 25% off it's a great
gift go check it out right now again the
last coat comm slash Sunday special and
Sunday 25 at checkout to take advantage
of the limited time offer okay so let's
talk for a second about the answer that
question let's pick up the classical
liberal mantle for a second and argue in
favor of the idea that the the argument
about borders is that classical
liberalism still has the requirement to
protect its own values meaning if you
don't agree with classical liberalism
you don't get to come in so would be a
completely ideologically based border
argument that classical liberalism says
you know yes free and equal individuals
who are coming together on the basis of
consent but we don't consent so you
can't come in
why couldn't you pay some border policy
on that well my first problem with it
before we even get to the board of my
first problem with it is is that I just
think it's an extremely weak political
theory all right now I'm speaking just
you know from the perspective of you
know science or from you know political
theory we we want to simplify the
political world so that because
simplifying it makes it easier for us to
understand things right so so our minds
need simplification I'm not against that
but there's a difference between you
know really powerful and and useful
simplification and really dumb
simplification all right so so to me
dumb simplification is when you take
human beings whose fundamental political
characteristic is that is that they
develop these that they're sticky that
they develop these mutual loyalties to
one another that a family is an
incredibly strong thing and a tribe's
incredibly strong thing and
and the reason that that a small nation
or a tribe can stand up to world empires
is because of its cohesion because of
the fact that the the the mutual loyalty
and the willingness to sacrifice for one
another that that that is something that
makes these human groupings unbelievably
strong so my first objection is to the
way that we the way we learn political
theory in in every introduction to
political theory course where the
central the central characteristic of
human beings that makes political order
is completely ignored and then you can't
understand what's going on that I mean
that that's my major problem then if we
take the specific example of the border
the the reason that human societies have
borders is is because of this of this
clustering where you know Jordan
Peterson does a really good job of
convincing young people that actually
human beings are hierarchical in nature
that we that we only feel good if we
join into a community you know which has
leaders which has or elders which passes
down a tradition and I think that that's
that that's simply true so now if you
take a map of you know a geographical
map and you look at where where the
different tribes are and you try to
figure out you know who's loyal to who
so you'll be able to draw a rough
borders they'll know I already said
they'll never be perfect right you'll
never get them exactly right but you'll
be able to draw rough borders and you
say okay within this territory that that
particular tradition is going to get to
determine with the laws and what the
norms are and some other territory the
the other tribe which has a different
different tradition of different norms
they're going to be able to that's the
reason for federalism right I mean the
whole concept of federalism comes from
an awareness that human beings are are
fundamentally tribal in the if you want
have any kind of freedom and and even a
little bit of peace you need to let them
to to to work out their own stuff right
so I think that's where borders come
from and I'm not saying that consent is
not important in politics I never said
that but it's so much less important
than in
just describing the reality than this
the children are born into families and
they develop loyalties not every child
is going to be loyal to what they were
taught but in general children are born
into families and it's those families
that teach them what nation what tribe
and what nation and what tradition to be
loyal to and even even you know I've I
have plenty of teenagers and they they
rebel the program to rebel you know they
resist and they push the boundaries but
they're always pushing the boundaries
outward from the traditions that they
inherited from their family and their
community so even if they rebel and they
move over there still they've moved over
from a baseline that comes from where
they're children that is not based on
consent consent plays a role but
fundamentally it's about something else
that human diversity human ingenuity
creates these different societies with
different ways of living and if you want
there to be a chance at peace between
them you have to have good borders good
borders make good neighbors that's the
biblical idea even though it wasn't said
quite like that by Moses and I don't
want people pretending that you know
that that it's about consent because
then they'll start to say well if we
could get the Iraqis to consent to
American government then the Americans
should be running Iraq right no no no
you can't do that you can't get there
from here
the Americans should just not be running
Iraq period so I want to ask about
yeah the thinning out of conservatism so
you mentioned that before conservatism
that included the biblical tradition
included religion included common bonds
and certain social fabric being thinned
out toward basically just free markets
and I agree that that's happened one of
the things that troubles me is that the
kickback has not been in favor of the
rebuilding of social fabric in a lot of
areas the kickback has been in favor of
an anti free-market tendency which is to
say well free markets ought to be
overthrown in favor of the quote
so-called common good you hear language
used like well shouldn't the market work
for us and I just keep thinking that is
a fundamental misunderstanding of what
free markets represent I mean in the end
free markets represent the idea that I'm
capable of alienating my own labor they
don't represent and something that you
hitched to the wagon and family and then
we all get to combine together and then
figure out how to invade each
there's rights in order to in order to
benefit the common good especially in
the violation of something just steal
some rich guys money and now you've
benefited a bunch of families so it
seems to me that that the the kickbacks
you conserved it to a thinned out
conservatism a sort of libertarian
minded conservatism with regard to
government that stretched out into the
societal realm when war went too far has
been in the wrong area that the push
back actually should be a real rien
Caucasian of a lot of the same values
that were lost not a push back against
the free market I think that's a fair
objection I mean you you know that I've
been I've been involved in in the last
couple of years in in organizing in
America in Europe with what hopefully is
going to turn out to be a a thoughtful
national conservatism which is my hope
is that it's going to be an appropriate
response to this sort of rampant
libertarianism and or neoconservatism on
the one hand and then the the rising
white identity politics on on the right
both of which I oppose and and I see
exactly what you're saying I mean I
actually think that there's what what's
happened is that the conservative
movement as it turned to economics as
kind of the the sole issue that people
really need in order to understand
politics I'm exaggerating a little bit
but but not to address but not too much
and and so as it moves in that direction
what happens is that this impoverished
understanding of what politics is about
leads people who they feel that
libertarianism has gone too far or they
feel the Republican Party has gone too
far in the direction of an Rand or
Robert Nozick or Milton Friedman and I
think that they're they're seeing things
that are you know there are real
problems I mean like the the the the
issue of to what extent did did did
America's unwillingness to take China
seriously as a rival and to say okay
America's companies are gonna move to
China well it's a free market there's
nothing you can do about it that is a
serious problem and a serious question
but I completely agree with with with
that that the debate has is along this
more government internment intervention
in the economy less intervention in the
government intervention in the economy
axis nobody talks about all right and
this is I mean almost nobody other than
I'm exaggerating a little bit but in in
general conservative politics in America
and in the UK and and in Europe is all
about economics and about where how much
government interventions there going to
be as soon as you start talking about
these other things then then religion
and nationalism then people come back
and they say they start giving you
economic answers like like there's an
opioid addiction problem so we need an
economic we need an economic answer to
that there's a God in Scripture are
disappearing you know not even from from
liberal just liberal communities but
even Christian communities are having
trouble you keep it keeping their their
kids within the tradition and the answer
is a charter schools which is an
economic answer and I'm not against
charter schools but the problem is you
you just can't
economics will not solve these problems
we need a political theory that takes
human beings as they are which means
that we have to recognize that there is
such a thing as Co is cohesion we have
to figure out what family cohesion is
about tribal and national cohesion we
have to figure out what we actually need
to do to encourage those things now if
you're if you're Hayek then you may very
well say to me that every single thing
that I come up with isn't is it is like
a government intervention and so I'm a
fascist like let's say I want Bible
I want Bible in the schools I mean I at
this at this point I'm not talking about
like forcing people to be religious I'm
just talking about the total ignorance
that of Americans about their own past
which which is never going to stop as if
we can't put Bible back in the schools
the answer to that is to understand what
the American nation is to understand
that it's not a race but to understand
that it does
traditions to figure out what are the
most important things in those
traditions and to to say it's a priority
to teach those things now if you can do
it through charter schools so I'm with
you but if you can't do it through
charter schools and I've been hearing it
I mean I'm not against them but I've
been hearing about this my whole life
I've been hearing about charter schools
gonna solve this problem
I want a discussion about why Americans
simply beginning in the 1940s they they
wiped Christianity and Bible and the
entire heritage the the entire set of
ideas out of the school systems and
created a country that is just like us
in which every school is a safe space in
which you'll never ever get to hear
about God or scripture or what they gave
your ancestors that's totally nuts if
you want the country to the future if
you want to have a future it has to have
a past so I'm happy to look I live in a
socialist country no one dislike
socialism as much as I do right I I mean
I pay 50 roughly 50 50 percent income
tax seventeen percent value added tax
another 20 percent payroll tax plus
import taxes it's it's totally
intolerable
I don't want anybody to live like that I
don't want Americans to live like that
that's I'm not on that side but if
they're gonna tell me that that
economics which is the science of the
choosing free consenting individual can
answer the basic problems America has
today that's false so in the remaining
moments that we have left I'd be remiss
if I didn't ask you a question about the
socialist country from the State of
Israel so a lot of Americans on the
right obviously are very supportive of
the State of Israel they see commonality
cultural commonality as your religious
commonality in many cases increasingly
on the Left Israel has become
extraordinarily unpopular it's becoming
more popular in areas of the the
alt-right particularly or the the more
isolationist right paleo conservative
right what do you make of Israel's sort
of place in America right now where
Israel stands with the American people I
want to distinguish between the
alt-right and the paleo I mean these
labels are a little bit yet wishy and
fluid bitter sure there's a line you can
draw between the the rising white
identity movement which is I I've paid
careful attention to it in the last
couple of years
I'm very sorry to report that it is
overwhelmingly anti-semantic simatech
and they they detest israel i mean
sometimes they will facetiously say that
they like israel because they think that
israel is a racist state like they want
america to be but the i've looked at it
carefully most of them really detest
jews in israel i want to distinguish
between that and the the old paleo
conservative right which had lots of
problems with israel and saw israel as
kind of hostile to their worldview when
what they were doing was fighting
universal liberalism right when
universal liberalism the new world order
when that took over the republican party
they felt they had to fight it and they
saw israel being sold as look it's a
liberal democracy like america it's part
of the liberal empire and and they
resisted it i think i see a big change
taking place in those circles now where
israel's nationalism is being taken I'm
talking about people by people who are
not are not racists and they're looking
to Israel as nationalists all across
Europe and in other countries are
looking to Israel as a model of a
successful national state and and not
only are they sympathetic but they that
they ask are there lessons that we can
learn from from Israel that can help us
with the disintegration of of the United
States I mean Israel has had plenty of
problems in my lifetime but at the
moment it's probably the strongest it's
ever been it's it's economically the
strongest but it also is the only
country in the world where I mean the
the the Jewish fertility rate is almost
double what it is in what the fertility
rate the in in most Western countries is
and it continues to rise you know there
you know there
it's a it's a very special place where
the the feeling of of national mutual
loyalty unites the left and the right
the religious and the non-religious of
course there's tensions and fights but
Israel's a very cohesive country and the
the nationalist in the United States now
they look at Israel Israel has border
walls Israel has very restrictive
immigration policies Israel has a
burgeoning free market sector but it
also has a willingness to to intervene
too much I've already said way too much
but these these are things that allow
the American nationalist right to
rethink Israel and think of it in terms
of an alliance and the more anti Israel
the left becomes the more the
nationalist American right seems to be
moving in this direction of re
identifying and I say we identifying
because of course the ancestors right of
like Anglo Americans or Dutch Americans
or Scottish Americans that their their
ancestors saw biblical Israel as a as a
model for them and some of that is
beginning to come back
seeing Israel as as a helpful model for
what America might someday be okay so in
a second I'm Nazca the final question
which is what do you see the future of
America has and what do you see the
future of Israel as in the next few
years but if you want to hear your
husbandís answer you have to be a daily
water subscriber so to subscribe head on
over to daily wire.com click subscribe
you can hear the end of our conversation
over there well your Mazzoni the book is
the virtue of nationalism thanks so much
for stopping that really appreciated
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy Boren associate producer Colton
Haas our guests are booked by Kaitlyn
Manor post-production is supervised by
Alex Singaram editing by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Camino hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera title
graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright day Lee Weyer
2019 thanks for tuning in but before you
go don't forget guys head on over to
daily wire comm subscribe to our
all-access membership and use the promo
code DW books and you'll get a free sign
book from knowles and a free sign book
from me along with all of the goodies
that come with a daily wire subscription